you start with a question to the
public who knows the problem of
blue algae
the majority of you then we
all agree that it is a
serious problem there is no one who wants to
drink contaminated water by the goodbyes
nobody blushes to swim
in a lake contaminated by
blue algae either, is it not so do
n't be disappointed today I do
n't want to talk about blue algae but
on the contrary I was talking to you about the causes
is the main cause that leads us
to this problem there and that causes this is
what I called the
phosphorus crisis why today did
I choose to talk to you about this
phosphorus crisis quite simply because
there is no one who  we are talking and
I would like that at the end of my
presentation that the citizens that the
public be aware of this
gold crisis and of this problem not
then the problem and announce to them I
ask the question from where to see what  'we
have come here with blue algae the
problem and is shown which comes from
our agriculture in our agriculture
which use fertilizers
chemical fertilizers
why do deer use them
in china is simply
to help plants grow and
to have a better yield the
problem unfortunately that this will
cause an environmental problem
so its president
so we are going to do a little course in
plant biology so before
starting then a plant what does
it need to grow so a
plan  simply needs
light it needs co2 but more
important than that it needs a and
rim years that will go exhausted
inside the balance between these
nutrients of which there are several
essential chemical elements
phosphorus  the zot and the calcium then its
roots will go to draw on its
resources there and today I want to
focus more on a major problem
which is related to phosphorus for times
phosphorus exactly because it is
the element which is the most  problematic
then you will see that at the end of my
presentation
what are these problems there he sees
what we have become
then presents phosphorus as distinct sets of
chemical elements an element that is
essential to life and that is very
important never  that everyone
understands exactly along the fossate
phosphorus is a main constituent
of several molecules of our molecules molecules
of life for
connoisseurs it is
cellular communication is based on the fossate
false revelations of phosphorylation
our structures the membranes of the
cells are phosphorus-based so
we're talking about phospholipids
the energy in our body from everything
that lives there tp it's
phosphorus-based even more important
phosphorus is a main constituent
of d1 while everyone knows
as you can see the six in
this picture so when we talk about
dna it's our genetic heritage
it's extremely important and if
phosphorus again it's a
main player so now where do
we go  going to get so this this phosphorus phosphorus
for us
either we wonder that we will
look for them when I explained earlier the
plants will go and draw from the inside
so the balance so through the water
afterwards so we  let's enter it's not therefore
via what we eat parents
plants fruits vegetables but
also eggs meat and milk
indeed so we humans there are some
who eat better than others there are some
who are  happier than the other is
now in coudron let's look at this
image there which speaks for itself so
modern agriculture where does what I
will also call
intensive agriculture intensive agriculture
based on chemical fertilizers on
fertilizers are fertilizers we
would not be able to produce
enough to feed all the humans
and speaking of humans currently there
are seven billion humans on
earth of whom less than 40 years old we would be 9
billion and the question is simple are
we sufficiently  phosphorus to
feed our future generations in his
accounts so to understand these issues
where are we going to get the
phosphorus at their game
then explains to you another PACS in
the round getting there let's now suppose
that we use a dose of
100% phosphorus on this 100% phosphorus the 15%
is to the plant and 85% is lost
it is enough depending on the soil it will end its
journey in the lakes of illac no more
phosphorus algae problem there you
will see here you  going to say there is
something wrong something
that is not logical we put his % of
phosphorus there 15% probes aa the plant
you are going to tell me it's a waste
yes it's a waste even worse than
it costs  very expensive so
nobody wants to throw their money out
the window unfortunately that's what is
happening now on a dose of
phosphorus 80% are lost
so now our
model agriculture is based on the share of phosphorus
and strong  per m because barely 15%
are good for the plant everything else is
lost we have to put more and more
so now it's where are we going to
get this phosphorus
the supply will simply be we're going
get them from the mines what
you got so it's an
extraordinary article that was published as an appendix
in 2009 that really started to talk
about the phosphorus crisis the
phosphorus problem on an essential nutrient
for life which is  disappearing
and no one talks about it and everyone
agrees politicians scientists
agree we're really heading
a phosphorus crisis is what you
see here it's an open pit mine
in the United States and to give you an
idea of ​​size and the size of 7000
looking at the top right the small
crane that you see it is a grid which
is giant so it really gives me a
little bit so the size of its  class
so we're going to get so that
phosphorus from the mines and if I
make a comparison with oil oil
indeed so there's a
crisis we're talking we're talking about
global warming but we're not talking about the
phosphorus crisis so if I believe  still the
problem of oil the barrel of oil
we can replace it we can use
biofuel we can use
solar energy we can use fin
energy but phosphorus stern
essential elements essential to life we
cannot replace it
so now  have we reached the
world's phosphorus reserves
in this curve shows you a little
bit so where have we reached
right now the curve in black mount
shows us the predictions where
have we reached  in 2030 we will reach the peak
at the end of the century there will be more the
dotted curves shows us wascon
must have had to be presently so
actually so it was stuck for two years
in 2030 I will be retired at this
time but we are heading
indeed in a really
major problem and that's what
I would like people to become
aware of this problem so wait for
solutions
how are we going to do we
find ourselves in a paradox
we will see less and less  in 2050 we
would be 9 billion and according to the halle at the
organization of the
united nations for
food and agriculture
in 2050 we must double the
agricultural production that we have today then on the one
hand less phosphorus and we must  produce
more what are we doing
so we really find ourselves faced with a
paradox where there are solutions or where
an alternative that will make it possible
to optimize the use of transport
remember that 80% that we are going to put
and  will be lost
then the solution
that I am proposing today is quite
simply a solution that has existed
for a very long time long before
plants existed on earth which is a
small,
very mysterious microscopic fungus, very simple and
extremely complex and for more than
16 years in this  small mushroom so
impressed me so it actually attracted me
to bring me so to deepen my
research and it is a model that
I use so turn to research
to study it in the laboratory so this
mushroom there it goes  live in symbiosis
with the roots so when we talk about
symbiosis a
two-way association the two partners
benefit from it and in this association we call
the one but
then corrects the mycorrhiza I will explain to you
here so you see him a
root of the glay one of the plants so  the
most important will fall the root on
its own will get phosphorus but
it will get them phosphorus yes
but call the 1 mm which will surround
this root beyond 1 mm the root
and ineffective it cannot
get phosphorus imagine
now  the mushroom the champion island
tiny and the microscopic it has a
much faster growth alas
a much more effective ability to
seek phosphorus it will
extend beyond this zone
exploited by the root to
seek phosphorus I absolutely have
nothing invented it's a technology that
has existed for 450 million years and
this fungus there it has quite simply
evolved and is adapted to seek out
the slightest corner of phosphorus to
exploit it to make it available to
the plant so now so on
this breed and real demand
so you see there a root of the carrot
you see the fungus very fine with
these filaments and when you look closely at it
this fungus so it will penetrate
in a jaunty way so I preferred between
the cells at the  inside the root
is after a certain time it will
penetrate inside a cell and
will begin to form a
typical structure which is called the art of the
skull and this structure simply
will not allow d  considerably increase
the exchange interface between the
fungus and the plant and it is through
this structure that there will be
exchanges it is an exchange which
gives them a give and take I give you phosphorus
and you feed me so it  is really a
true symbiosis
so now this game uses the same
graphic we will use a plant with
mycorrhizae and instead of using a
dose of 100% I will reduce it to 25%
so on its 25% you will see the
big  part will benefit the plant,
i.e. more than 90%, very few will attach themselves to the
ground level in a natural way
because they will attach themselves to lambs
and even more so in some cases we do
n't even need to put the phosphorus
you remember the graphs that I
showed you uncle 85% will get lost
in the ground yes they will attach themselves there but
the plants
cannot have access to it even if it
is present in the ground and in an
unusual form and  the plant what it can
get is only the
forms that are soluble the
fungus is capable of going to
solubilize this insoluble form and
thus make them available to the plant
so to convince you so that's
really an image that speaks for itself
these are field trials in
sorghum production of which you have on one
side so on the right we used
conventional agriculture with a
dose of phosphorus at 100%
on our side we have  reduced a dose to 50%
and look at the performance with a dose
that is low by 50% or not a better
performance so this to show it is
something that we had received
something that works and that works and
in certain cases in particular  in cuba in
mexico in india we can reduce to 25% and
therefore in many cases we don't even
need to put any because they are
adapted to really get the
phosphorus from that
so there again c  this is another example
in productions said death in
canada so on their fate in the evening you
see in a field in which
in 15 years we have used mycorrhizae and
a field where we have not studied but
corrects and in this case there  there is really
a better yield so visible so
it's on the color index so
blue we have a better yield of the genre
we have less yield and the square the
black rectangle so it's the parcel
from which moment  added
mycorrhiza so in other words
mycorrhiza as I said nothing invented
so it has existed in nature for 450
million years which has even helped
plants to diversify laddh
nowadays still so it's not
something that  we are testing mycorrhiza in the
laboratory so it exists it
works it is produced on
an industrial scale it is
marketed through storytelling and the
problem that arises is that people
are not aware of that and still
producers and farmers do
not know this probable so we
really have a technology that works
and it is a technology if we
use them and that we exploit it
correctly we will quite simply make it possible
to release the pressure
that we are currently exerting  on the
world reserves of phosphorus
so indeed so to finish my
ankle a scientist on a dreamer
so I would like to be passionate but if
you ask the question what would be my
dream when I resume retirement
actually when we will reach the peak
of phosphorus in my  dream it would be
that we use a label with the ball with
my coryses that my children or but all
your children will buy at the market that
it's ok you mark and produce by
empty words and I thank you for your
attention